Okay.
Hey,
what's going on is bill burn is time for the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
May 7th,
2018 what's going on?
How is ya?
How's it going?
How are you?
Is your hockey team still alive in the NHL playoffs?
While you know what?
Congratulations.
I hope you're happy because mine isn't.
Mine is not.
Mine is done for the Goddamn season.
I do want.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I hit the printer while doing the podcast.
Oh,
fucking consideration.
For the high level of quality of a program that's going on in here.
Why would you do that?
You come in here and you apologize to the incredible intellect of my listeners.
Sorry.
Yeah.
I just,
yeah,
I hit print.
Sorry.
Oh my God.
Mia,
can we sit down and talk about how you cut up that steak last night?
Nope.
Oh,
were you running?
Were you running to build it?
Why would you listen to this?
You want to talk about one of one of the shadiest moods ever moves ever come in
and shut down.
Shut down.
Gorgeous.
We'll bring her in here.
They'll take some of the sting out of what I'm going to say to you is so
anyways,
so we go out,
you know,
a friend of ours in town and of course she wanted to meet our lovely,
beautiful,
absolutely charming.
Always in a great mood.
Gorgeous daughter.
Right now we love showing a rough,
we love getting the compliments.
Oh my God.
I know right?
I did that.
You know I didn't,
I took a half court shot and God did the rest of the law.
Um,
anyways,
so we ended up going out to a steak house,
right.
Sydney has like,
I don't want to stake but I'd like some steak.
Are you going to order a steak?
And it's like,
yes.
When in Rome.
Hi.
Did you just say hi to me?
You say hi to the listeners.
Qt.
So Nia is just like,
can you kind of kid a steak?
I don't want stay on a whole steak.
I wanted to get tuna tar,
tar and I wanted a crab.
The lump crab cake,
which is what you ordered.
And I wanted a little bit his day cause I want to do a little surf and turf.
Yeah.
So what does all freckles to what is all freckles still he key orders of course.
What do you order?
Oh Billy steg face.
I ordered the bone in Ribeye.
How the hell did that happen?
Sorry,
what just happened there?
Somehow I moved in,
the volume got turned down anyways,
I'll have to edit that part out.
So anyways,
I'll Billy stake face.
I order a bone in Ribeye.
So Cutie Pie here starts getting frustrated.
Nah,
starts making noise and I,
you know,
I don't want to be that guy at the restaurant with the baby that's crying
specially in a steakhouse steak house.
You have a lot of people,
they're in their second marriages.
People who you know,
didn't get married,
guys who are paying for a house that they're no longer allowed to go into.
You know,
there's a lot of that go in,
you know,
a lot of child support being paid,
by some of these people who had to rebuild it again.
So it'll add lead.
You have belly hanging out.
Let me give Kelly hanging out.
What are you doing?
So she was,
my daughter was getting frustrated,
so I just started,
I started,
you know,
walking around the restaurant and everything.
Like that being the amazing father that I am right running around,
she's so short,
I got to like,
you know,
bend it that angle,
then it's like killing my back.
But I,
but I stuck it out.
I did it for you.
I did it for all those divorcees in there.
Right.
All those people paying child support,
even though the women that women are starting to pay child support to.
Oh you haven't seen it,
you haven't read that.
And cosmo,
cosmo,
yeah.
Yeah.
And they out there,
they're complaining that which I love.
I love this whole equal pay cause you wait and you wait till enough women have
to start paying child support and you watch those divorce laws change.
Um,
so anyways,
while I'm being the amazing father than that,
I am obviously,
this is my,
uh,
this is my version of the story.
Uh,
my stake arrives.
So Nia goes to cut off her portion of the steak.
And basically what she does is she cuts the thing like length wise,
right a lot like an inch away from the bone and she takes all the meat along the
bone and then gives me the rest of it.
And for those of you who aren't meaty,
there's all you've vegetarians out there,
the most flavorful part of a bone in Ribeye.
The reason is is all along the bone.
And she took the best meat and I was so upset with her,
I told her that she needed to go to ancestry.com because that was some northern
white European shit.
What you just did there?
Uh,
yeah,
I'd say the,
I did.
That's my favorite.
Fired the bone.
I
all right guys,
she ever want to know.
If you want to know what it's like to be a husband and a father,
that's what it is.
She makes the baby.
She goes through all of that.
She goes through nine months of hell,
10 months of hell.
Actually this,
the middle three.
That's like the summer vacation,
but whatever.
We'll say 10 months of hell and you know what?
And then as a guy,
you pay for it for the rest of the relationship.
She gets it all back with little f little shady cuts of bone in Ribeye.
I couldn't believe that.
Hi.
Hi Cutie.
He's smiling at you,
Huh?
She is in love with you.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
and I'll be in love with her until the day she takes the,
the good part of my cheerios.
All right.
Hi.
How are you,
Cutie.
All right,
daddy has to talk filthy so I can still buy your diapers.
That's how it works.
I'm sorry I'm too far down this road to pretend that you have a respectable
dead.
All right,
lovely ladies.
Well,
I mean thought that you were going to try to defend your position and you didn't
you like,
yeah,
I did.
That's what I did.
I mean,
that's,
that's really all there is to say.
I did.
I saw that
meet along the loans.
You're doing Donald Trump right now and what does that,
that's how he got out of stuff.
You said all this horrible stuff about women and he's like,
no,
I said that about Rosie O'donnell.
And they were like,
no,
you said that about other women.
He was like,
yeah,
you're probably right.
It's like all right.
I thought that was going to be a big funny fight and it was nothing out.
You're on my ankle.
Okay.
All right ladies.
Bye Bye.
Can you say bye bye
bye bye.
All right.
Oh well yeah,
I'll see you later.
Bye.
If she's Burton your leg.
Oh okay.
You get my sake and I get a cheaper later.
Let me guess.
Mcdonald's,
what do you guys want?
What do you like Betty?
Like Mcdonald's or Burger King?
I've always,
I've always been a McDonald's guy.
Oh he's been Mcdonald's and I know it's not like I'm out here looking for
another advertiser.
I'll tell you right now,
I feel the best poisoned in fast food is Mcdonald's.
This is how I would,
I would rank.
So I ranked my fast food cheeseburgers,
Nia.
Oh,
okay.
All right.
As much as there's some great ones out there like in and out.
I have to go to Mcdonald's cause the child's sense memory.
Okay.
You know that just takes me back to,
you know,
when my bicycle was orange,
just like my hair that I used to have and I had the white tape around the handle
bars.
[inaudible] tell you what happened.
I went to the,
um,
to see my trainer and when I got in there,
oh yeah.
Did you take the Best Matt in the gym?
Yes.
And he was finishing up with another client and she had her daughter there who
was like four years old and she's so cute.
So I was like,
oh,
you want to see pictures of my baby?
And so I was showing her pictures of the baby and then she saw a picture of you
with the baby and she goes,
who's that?
And I said,
Oh that's,
I'm her daddy,
that's my husband.
And she goes,
okay.
She goes,
why does he have any hair?
Who said that the kid can the fourth girl.
And I said,
well,
you know,
sometimes when people get older,
their hair starts to come out,
and so he just decided to cut it off because he didn't want it just to be
falling on it.
I think it looks better this way,
and she was like,
yeah,
that's true.
Why did I need to know that there was a cute already feel bad enough about
myself?
Do you want me to kids who looked at me and said,
you're ugly in my life?
How may at least six.
No,
I swear to God we won.
I had hair.
No.
Yeah,
children and children are honest.
I know what all you adults to do and you'd just be a nice to me.
Maybe you deserve that bone in Ribeye and just give me the ship,
right?
Ai.
Yeah.
Ugly piece of Shit.
Get outta here,
Nina.
Like that cute story.
Neal
and I met this girl the other day and she,
I showed her a picture of you and she was like,
hey,
why is her butt's so big?
And I was like,
well,
you know,
you bought as in pig.
All right,
but now I'm going to fucking pay father,
you're going to laugh at that and I'm going to pay for that comment forever,
right?
You can just,
you can just eviscerate me
child that's senate.
So I don't know why you're making up some scenario where someone's insulting
like my looks that's not a child.
And for the record,
my ass might be big,
but it's like perfect.
So
it is,
it's why I married you would certain wasn't certainly wasn't the other end
rather end.
I have no problem with the,
is she a fucking Yap.
That drives me up the wall.
All right.
Whatever.
Why,
why,
why do I try to make a point?
Why do I try to get ahead?
They know what I mean.
It's just like bill,
you'll lose it.
Okay.
You're at a casino and the House always wins in the house is you fucking wife.
So just fucking cash in your chips and go back to the Goddamn Room.
Anyways,
let's get back to the NHL playoffs.
Congratulations to the fucking expansion.
Tampa Bay lightning.
I don't hate you guys cause I love Steve,
ours,
him and,
and I know he's in your front office so I'm happy for him.
All right.
Okay.
Having said that,
you guys were the better team no matter how bad the officiating was.
It was bad for both sides.
Um,
and no matter what I think you guys still use,
you just were a better team.
He just rebelled a team,
no matter what you were going to win.
But I will say this,
this officiating straight across the board in the NHL playoffs,
not just arguing for my team has been really a unprofessional,
really unprofessional.
There's always a couple of calls here or there,
but like,
it's reminding me of NBA officiating last decade when I called it,
I said it was fixed.
I'm not saying it's fixed,
this is coming off more like,
I feel like it's like,
did the real refs go on strike?
And these are like some fucking scab refs.
They pulled out of the fucking crowd.
Um,
there was just a couple of like,
look,
you know,
Marshawn took that guy's fucking knees out.
They didn't make a call there,
which I thought was bullshit.
And uh,
you know,
I know we were licking people's faces and that is no rule against that yet.
I can guarantee you maybe now that the Bruins are knocked out,
maybe they'll,
they'll relax.
But I mean,
I thought if we advance to the next round,
they were going to make a quick rule that's going to be called the Marshawn
rule.
It's going to be no player Shell,
kiss,
lick tongue or in any manner use his facial or a fist
with inappropriate contact is going to be the,
there's going to be the bread,
Marshawn rule.
And someday if I live enough,
I will see Brad when he's in his seventies on the NHL Network,
laughing about it,
talking about how that rule came about and why he was doing what he was doing.
Um,
it's the most bizarre thing I've ever seen.
And it was,
it was,
it was hilarious.
And when they went back to the,
to studio,
Jeremy Ronek was,
is,
it was like,
it happened to him.
He's like,
I would have immediately gone to the showers and I was thinking like,
well,
that's great.
You're all of fame player.
Let's get you off the ice.
Um,
I had a buddy of mine actually texted me,
said,
not even Sean Avery licked another player.
And I was like,
yeah,
well he was too dumb to think of it.
And he goes,
well,
if he's that dumb,
why is he married to a supermodel?
And I said,
all right,
fair enough.
You got me.
Um,
anyways,
but just,
you know,
I mean,
what the fuck that guy,
the guy in Tampa,
like we really needed to win game four so we can lose in six games and we lose,
still going to lose the fucking template is his hands off his stick.
He hauls McAvoy down behind his own net,
behind his own fucking net,
no call.
It was,
it was the most obvious.
Not only did the announces,
when they went back to the fucking studio even,
they were like,
what the fuck?
Tampa takes it,
pass it over stamp cost and they tied a fucking game up and wheat instead of
having a chance to even this series at two two we go down three one it was just
stuff like that.
I,
you know it's funny as Barton,
nick was in Tampa Bay and he was listening to it on the radio and Esposito said
that it looked like a dive,
which is the funniest fucking thing ever.
Esposito.
I is still fucking pissed that he asked for like $3 more from the cheap ass
Boston Bruins 45 years ago and they ship them to New York,
our archrival other than the Canadians during that time.
So he will never be impartial when it comes to us.
But what the fuck?
Kind of who the fuck is going to dive behind their own net with the puck behind
your own fucking net when you're,
you're up by one and you have to win that playoff game or are you going to go
down three games to one?
I don't know.
He is Esposito.
He is a hall of Famer,
but that did not look like a dive to me.
And having said all this fucking sour grape shit,
I know Tampa's still would've won.
I know they probably would've wanted to.
Probably six games is what I think would have happened.
They just had too much fire power.
And I think by the time we decided to get physical in the series it was too
late.
But um,
that's what was missing in our game this year,
I think against Toronto and against Tampa,
which both of them I felt had more firepower than we did is when you're playing
a team that has,
you know,
faster than you and has more gold scores,
you have to get physical with them.
You can't just let them fucking skate around.
And I think we just waited too long,
but haven't said that this rebuild is on an upswing.
I mean,
I thought that we were going to be bad for a good six,
seven seasons.
I didn't see the light at the end of the tunnel.
So I'm very happy that we,
uh,
we want to play off series advanced to the second round.
It's definitely a very successful year and a,
we're going to have a new rule named after one of our players to Marshawn rule.
Maybe it's a good thing that we lost in five.
If there was any more games,
he might've been the first guy to get a fucking meat to case from another guy,
right?
Oh No,
no,
wait,
that one guy did.
The agent did with the other guy from the cop show.
All right.
I guess everything's been done.
Is that what it is?
Has everything been done in the whole time?
This is what kills me is I'm watching the Bruins,
you know,
just fucking losing this series lick and people's faces and shit.
And I,
I missed every single second of the Celtic 70 sixers.
You know,
I just,
I had to pick a road.
So busy.
I've got the kid and all that and I only had time and I missed,
I guess one of the most epic Celtics Games in recent memory where they tied it
up at the buzzer against the sixers.
And then came back and won in overtime.
All I'm hearing is Rosier Tatum Brown.
How much this stepping up Al Horford I guess was a blocking shots like a maniac.
And uh,
so now I gotta
I gotta I gotta I have,
I have all the time in the world to watch the Celtics now.
So that's what I kind of realized.
You know,
as much as I love the Celtics and everything,
I really am a hockey guy because I knew we were going to lose that series and I
still hung in there and wash it.
Although I missed yesterday's game because I was at a kid birthday party and
awesome kid birthday party,
like a,
you know,
you know when parents do a kid birthday party,
right?
You take notes.
These people did a great,
they didn't have it at their house.
They had it at like a function room.
There was an outdoor area,
there was a little jumpy house.
This guy did a bubble show,
you know,
he had a good set to man.
That's a tough crowd.
You know,
kids trying to keep them,
you know,
their attention.
They had booze for the,
the parents,
they had great food,
you know.
And then,
uh,
over in the corner they had this area where the kids,
you know,
one of those playpens that has like a zillion
different multicolored balls and all that type.
And it's just,
my kid was totally entertained the whole time.
I don't think I saw any kid crying just until the very end with the kids,
you know,
they need a nap and then just like,
I don't want it.
But
it was a great time.
So,
uh,
somebody there asked me,
cause you Bruins playing right now.
I'm like,
I'm afraid to look.
So it was kind of looking down and looking at the scores and then all my Boston
friends was sending me texts going,
what the fuck are we doing?
These refs suck.
The refs really did suck.
Um,
you know,
who knows,
they probably still would've maybe tied it up and beat us in five.
Who the fuck knows?
But I'm just saying,
you know,
I just hate having that,
like
that God damn feeling,
you know,
it's like that year the Lakers beat us,
which sucks enough.
But if the Lakers,
it's fine.
I can live with that to the fucking Lakers,
you know what I mean?
But you know,
you call like thirtysomething files on one team and you know,
in the teens on the other and a game seven,
it's just inexcusable.
Unless we were out there hacking people up and it just,
I dunno fucking drives me up the God day.
Those are the ones that stay with me.
You know what I mean?
I don't give a fuck if he just come in and kick our ass,
but we don't.
I,
but I,
I do take peace in the fact that Tampa Bay was definitely the better team and,
and I feel it
easily could have just beat us at six.
Um,
as much as,
I hate to admit any motherfucker anyways,
plowing ahead,
what's going to go on with the capitals or the capital's finally going to get
over the Hump and slay the dragon and beat these goddamn penguins from
Pittsburgh or the Pittsburgh penguins going to continue their march to be the
first team since the New York Islanders is Steve Byrne reminded me yesterday,
just the New York islanders to win three in a row.
It's been that long.
The island is actually won four in a row from 80 to 84.
And um,
I remember demo the one on the cover the next year of sports illustrated and
they said the strive for five to assume you know,
the rate,
one of the rare times sports illustrated put a hockey player back then,
you know,
on the cover.
And I think it was Mike Bossy,
if I remember correctly.
And um,
okay.
Yeah,
that was the age of dynasties when I grew up,
when I think about it from like,
you look at the 70s in hockey Bruins,
one,
two flyers,
two and see Canadians one six.
So he had three teams,
basically won everything.
And then the previous decade it was,
it was Canadians beliefs and then the Blackhawks won one.
Um,
and then I think Canadians want five and and the least one four,
cause I want to say the least one like three in a row.
And then one in 67 and the Blackhawks won is 61 and everything else was the
Canadians,
if I remember correctly.
Um,
and then you went to the eighties,
then the islanders.
So basically after the,
the,
uh,
it went Bruins,
Canadians,
Bruins can age flyers,
flyers.
Then Canadians,
Canadians,
Canadians and islanders,
islanders,
Edmonton,
Canadians,
Edmonton.
Then cow beat the fucking Canadians.
I one of my favorite one,
landing macdonald,
the Ginger,
um,
and then add mutton again in [inaudible] 90
and then 91 92 was the penguins.
And that was like immediate talking a,
I mean,
you could literally go back all the way to the 50s cause I know like the
Redwings one like back to back and everything else was just,
it was just fucking basically pre 1967 if you had to guess who won the cup that
year,
either guests,
Canadians or may beliefs.
Um,
but then all of a sudden,
you know,
once,
you know the,
the expansion six and 67 and then they added a,
you know,
Edmonton Oilers and all those guys and like I believe 78 or something like that.
And then it was a 2018 league and it just took a little bit,
well actually island was where expansion team in the early seventies.
Then they got al La,
they went on that run.
But uh,
then after that,
after the penguins went back to back,
it's just basically,
but every other year it's like somebody else wins it other than the one,
the red wings one,
two in a row.
And I think,
uh,
the penguins right now,
right.
It's not how it goes.
I don't fucking know.
Um,
but anyways,
which is why I hate to say this is a Celtics fan.
I think the,
uh,
the Lakers are,
they,
they're the most successful franchise,
um,
in the modern era because they were able to during free agency win championships
at a clip that people,
one before,
you know,
back when there was like a,
if you were a Laker you or a lake or go fuck yourself,
you're not going somewhere else unless the owner decides,
um,
haven't said that.
You know,
the Lakers do have a championship,
uh,
that,
you know,
there was a mobbed up ref and fucked over the Sacramento Kings that year.
I'm not saying the kings would have wanted,
but the Lakers would not have gotten a banner that year.
And then that other one with the fucking 37 files,
37 files in 48 minutes of the Celtics
and never forget Colby.
He goes,
I don't know how we won that game.
Well,
fucking talk to the guys with the athlete's foot shirts.
Um,
anyways,
sorry,
I'm just in a fucking bad mood cause my team lost.
Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead here.
Uh,
old Billy.
No vice
trudging along
into May.
I wanted to go at least a weekend to May cause I was just trying to go,
you know,
the,
the month of April,
basically vice lists and then I go into may and then I'm just like,
you know what,
I'm looking good.
I'm keeping the weight off.
I got the Big Five,
oh next month.
It would really be a shame if I got this close to my birthday.
Look in this good.
And then I just,
you know,
I just fucking,
put on that booze 10 pounds.
I don't want to do that.
But so,
uh,
I've been laying off,
laying off bored as shit went to that party yesterday.
There was booze there.
Could have had one 10 do it,
went to the steakhouse,
said all the beautiful fucking bottles behind the bar,
do it.
Came home,
trudge passed my bar.
They don't even say hi anymore.
Didn't do it.
Went downstairs,
took out my phone,
played solitaire on it,
fell asleep.
The exciting life of sobriety.
You know,
it's hard to,
as I watched the Kentucky Derby,
um,
I would have won money cause I always bet on that white haired guys horse cause
he's,
he's just a man.
He's the bill Belicheck at that shit.
And uh,
the year I went,
the only time I went,
what does that triple crown winner and he owned it.
I won money on that one.
And uh,
I was thinking if I was there,
I,
I always,
I always the Michael McDonald Guy of the horse racing owners and I was just
watching that,
that event.
And I was just,
I was like,
why am I not sitting here right now drinking some bourbon,
smoking a cigar,
right.
Watching it through my front window with the volume turned up.
Oh,
she can't smoke a cigar in the house,
but I didn't do it.
I just sat there,
you know,
I bought one of those TRX bands,
I'm going to go on the Internet,
still have my custom workout,
you know,
uh,
my shoulder feels really good.
It's really strong.
Uh,
I still haven't done a pull up and like two years.
oh actually,
no,
I did.
And then re-injured it,
you know,
six months ago.
So now I'm rehabbing it back.
So now I'm trying to go nice and frigging slow.
I got these bands.
Now I'm back into doing yoga.
I'm not fucking j good or not smoking and not bored shitless there.
I said it,
I'm fucking bored shitless.
Like people who are sober,
how the fuck,
you know?
You know what?
I actually finally I bought an external,
a little CD player to plug in so I could finally do my,
uh,
my Rosetta Stone French and um,
I've been doing that.
Then of course,
you know,
okay.
My wife helps me set the fucking thing up and then I,
uh,
you know,
it's working,
I'm having a great time and then I go to use it again.
And of course it won't fucking work.
It doesn't recognize anything.
I don't know how to open it up and it's just a fucking pain in the ass.
So hopefully at some point she'll take some time out of our day.
But anyways,
I'm going to polish up on that shit.
We tried to do an hour or two every single day right up until I get over to
France.
I just want to get a little bit better with my shit.
But uh,
you know,
at some point I gotta,
I gotta I gotta learn,
I gotta become fluent in French because I just think a fucking moron like me
knowing how to speak French,
this is just something,
it's too funny to not do it right.
Um,
okay.
I've actually ordered kids French books and I'm them to my daughter.
Those are great cause I was thinking like,
well how did I learn how to read English and speak it?
You know,
I had those little books being in Sandy.
Sandy had been,
do you remember that?
Did they still have those fucking books?
They were like these dogs.
That's what that is really is one of the most fascinating things ever is
learning how to read.
And you're a kid so you don't really remember like somebody like teaches you how
to fucking read.
Okay.
All right.
Let me see sandy and being,
they were a dog and a cat.
Okay.
See this?
Oh Man,
I'm going back 45 years shandy and buying books.
I swear to God,
if I see this,
this is going to freak me out to see these books
and of course it's not coming up.
Come on.
Yeah,
I the slowest Goddamn Internet ever.
Oh,
they don't even have them anymore.
Stanley big.
Some guy,
Stanley being wrote a book,
a hundred bullshit jobs and how to get them.
That is fucking hilarious.
Okay.
Why the hell would you do that?
Why?
Why would you,
oh my God.
Look at this book.
Yeah.
The bent,
the Bernstein bears in the mean drunk
and is it does a bear.
I swear to God,
wearing a wife beater holding a bat and it looks like a bottle of Jack Daniels.
This is why you got to love the Internet.
I'm looking up a kid's book
and I find a hundred bullshit jobs and how to get them and the Bernstein bears.
Am I saying that right and the mean drunk.
Okay.
Bingo.
Crosby,
Ghana,
some bugs bunny one.
All right.
Sorry.
What the fuck him.
You guys are literally listened to me surf the Goddamn Internet.
Um,
I had been doing a bunch of standup and popping in a bunch of places out here
getting ready for the gigs I have coming up that I do not deserve to be doing in
Ireland and in London,
Dublin and in London.
So I'm going to make sure I'm beyond on my game when I do those things.
I have a,
uh,
a run of dates coming up in San Francisco Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursday,
Friday.
I'm going to be up there with Nate Kraig Milwaukee Bucks Fan.
I'm not going to rub it in unless he brings it up.
Um,
and I'll be,
I'll be up there all week,
going to find a studio space with a drum kit.
I'm gonna fucking practice that bullshit.
I'm be doing my French and I'm not going to be drinking and I'm not going to be
smoking cigars.
A boy.
I don't know.
I,
there's no fucking way I'm going to do this.
I guess this is why people who are,
you know,
somebody actually asked me that the day if I wanted to go to a meeting.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
And I was just like,
dude,
I can't sit there with all this fucking donuts and people smoking cigarettes.
I'm just,
you know what I mean?
I'm just not,
I'm not that,
you know,
like I'm a,
I mean everything I ever fucking joint,
I was like,
I'm not this,
I'm liking this,
but I'm not quite this.
Even like playing drums.
As much as I love playing drums,
I know I'm not a musician.
Like when I got,
you see,
you know,
when you really see somebody that has the fucking gift,
do you like,
that's what that is.
I mean,
I can try to do this and make a really difficult life for myself.
It wasn't until I walked into a comedy club and open Mike and I saw all those
desperate lunatics and I'm like,
yeah,
this is,
this is me.
I'm this,
this is what I am.
So I went to an AA meeting,
I've gone to a couple of them.
Um,
they were required by the,
the fucking courts of Massachusetts.
I was required to go to two of those in a mother against drinking and driving
way back in the day when I got arrested with that shit back in the 80s,
you know?
MMM.
And I remember sitting there listening to these fucking stories and I was just
like,
Jesus fucking Christ.
Okay.
These people would have like head wounds and wake up from head wounds or stumble
out of jail barefoot and just stumble across the street directly over to a
liquor store.
I mean,
that is a fucking alcoholic.
You know,
they need help.
Okay.
To Stop.
I could stop on my own.
I might just justifying all of this.
That's what I'd be buddying the programs,
cause I can stop on my own and I just sit here and I'm just fucking bought,
just born out of my fucking mind.
It doesn't make any sense.
It's like I'm saying,
that's like saying I'm never going to have ice cream ever again.
It's like amber,
I could see not having it all the time,
seeing out of fat.
Fuck,
I get dad so your teeth don't rot out of your fucking head.
I was definitely drinking too much,
but like,
okay,
I'm never going to have it again.
We're going to go to the Kentucky Derby against someday.
God fucking willing.
I'm going to go to the Kentucky Derby again and I'm going to sit there stone
sober.
Okay.
I mean,
you go into the track.
I mean right there,
you're a degenerate.
Why not give into it?
I Dunno,
who knows?
But I will tell you,
I do love it in the morning when I wake up clearheaded in the morning,
it might,
pasty stomach is nice and flat.
I definitely,
I definitely enjoy that.
You know,
makes me a better dad.
I always make my daughter breakfast.
That's my thing every morning.
Right?
I'd go out and I get her,
I opened the door and she goes,
hi,
am I gay?
Right.
Excuse me.
A nice hug and a kiss.
Then,
uh,
you know,
change your,
put a Pajama bottoms across your eyes.
Where is she?
Where is she plays that game.
Loves it.
Still loving that game.
Right.
And um,
then I go upstairs.
She's really easy.
I cut up bananas,
strawberries,
blueberries.
Did I make her a couple of eggs scrambled.
Okay.
It's funny what I think you'd like to do is I like to have it all prepared
before I bring her upstairs because if I do,
you know,
cause if she's just sitting there,
she starts to get restless.
Like you know,
where's the food?
But if I have it all,
yeah.
Ready?
We other day I had it already,
you know,
and I brought her up but I put her in there,
a little chair and I put a bib on and all that and then I put the plate down
already ready and everything made and she just goes,
wow.
Now she goes,
Whoa,
it was awesome.
And she can feed herself.
The only thing I got to watch out for is she,
she wolfs down food the way I do.
So I just got to make sure I'm a
okay
just staying on her.
So I make sure I cut up everything nice and small,
spread out the egg.
So they cool off.
She doesn't burn them off and then that's it.
Give her a glass of water,
then it's all good.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
you know,
then I guess if I was hung over and it'll probably be a bad thing.
So then I think to myself,
what if I just get shit faced when I'm on the road?
I'm only on the road like four days a month.
That would be fine.
Right.
What do you guys say about that?
Oh,
well what do you say?
you guys and fucking Aa and I don't drink on the plane.
It's just after the shows.
It's gotta be a way to do it the way I used to be able to do it,
you know?
Do you know,
you know what the really thing that did fuck me up was I,
I,
I never used to have booze in the house.
So that's the problem.
So when I do start drinking again,
because I am going to start drinking,
what I'm going to do is I'm going to finish all the liquor in my house,
which even if I drank at a degenerate level,
would probably take me a good six months.
So I don't,
I don't know how I'm going to judge,
probably should have some people over and help them kill some of these bottles,
but I have such good booze,
I just,
I just can't give it away to some bum.
You know what I mean?
Like do you ever give a Cuban cigar to some guy who occasionally smokes and you
just watch him,
which is half the whole fucking thing down and you know,
you might as well give him a Dutch master.
Yeah.
That's the kind of booze I have.
So what I would like to do is slowly knock out all the booze over the next five
years than I have in the house and not replace any of the bottles.
And then,
because I think even back in the day when I lived in New York,
when I was living in New York and Derosa was living in New York,
um,
I mean we used to just get fucking annihilated.
Okay.
And uh,
but I never had any booze in the house.
Okay.
So in my apartment I should say.
So I think that that's,
I think that's right there was the game changers when I had it at home and then
had these nice fucking glasses.
You know,
when you really get into it,
like this is high level booze and these high level like you know,
the right glass and you get into the whole like ritual of it and you really can
trick yourself that you're not just being sub degenerate drinking alone.
You know what I mean?
You know he is a high ball glass,
so this is what you is a list of those glass here is for us.
Sam Adams beer actually have the Sam Adams glasses.
You know what,
that little lip at the top like it's supposed to make the head and the hops and
all of that tastes good.
It tastes the fucking same.
You know what I mean?
That's like when they do all these reissues of guitars,
you know what I mean?
I can't tell the difference the way I play guitar,
which I barely do anymore.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
you could give me the greatest guitar in the world.
I'm still going to sound like make,
which is shitty.
So anyways,
I don't know who the fuck knows,
but a buddy of mine is actually been listening to these tapes that,
you know,
talk about alcohol,
not,
and that's stupid.
You need to go to get help type of way,
but they just talk about,
they just put it in a different perspective.
Um,
I dunno,
I'm just like a streaky person.
That's all it is.
So like when I'm not drinking,
I don't want to drink cause I don't want to ruin the streak.
Oh my God,
man.
I've gotten like 35,
40 days here.
I'm gonna start all over again.
Let me see if I can make it to 50 because there's a big part of me that,
um,
you know,
would like to plow right through my birthday and not drink,
but then it's like,
I'm going to be in France.
How the fuck do you not drink when you're over there?
I'm not gonna have a fucking glass of wine.
Sit there like a fucking jerk off.
I don't know.
We'll see.
Anyways.
All right.
Zip Recruiter.
Zip.
Okay.
Recruit up.
Talk about the challenge of finding great talent and how the way you went about
it just did not work or was inefficient.
Well,
I'd love to tell you that that was a problem.
But,
uh,
I actually got lucky for somebody who was a fan of my podcast,
reached out to me by the name of Andrew Sam Willis.
And I've been working with them ever since,
you know,
and he's been great.
So I don't know what to tell you.
Simple ZipRecruiter knew there was a smarter way.
Well,
look,
obviously if I actually ran a business where I needed more than one frigging
employee,
okay.
And I don't want to waste time bringing people in and sitting there talking to
them and trying to find out if they came from divorce or you know,
how they did in school or go go check their Goddamn Facebook page to see what
they've liked or not liked.
Um,
this seems the easiest way to do it.
And you can just see if what shift through a entire,
the entire nation of qualified candidates.
Well,
Ziprecruiter knew that there was a smarter way,
so they built a platform that finds the right job,
job candidates for you,
learns what you're looking for,
identifies people with the right experience and invites them to apply to your
job.
These invitations that have revolutionized how you find your next hire.
In fact,
80% of employees who post jobs on zip
get a quality candidate through the site in just one day.
And ZipRecruiter doesn't stop there.
They even spotlight the strongest applications you receive.
So you never miss a great match.
That's right.
Oh,
sorry.
The right candidates are out there.
Sip
is how you find them.
Call to action.
Businesses of all tries his trust,
ZipRecruiter for high,
their hiring needs.
Right now my listeners can try ZipRecruiter for free.
That's right free.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/burr that's ziprecruiter.com/burr sip,
recruiter.com/burr.
They going to do it again?
Zip.
Well,
the smartest way to hire.
I got to save my voice here cause I got to record some.
F is for family is Fucko today.
All right,
movement,
MVMT movement watches.
Spring is right around the corner and movement is dropping all new sunglasses to
get your ready is dropping all new sunglasses to get you ready for the warmer
weather.
Uh,
we just got our goto shades for it all.
Who's we?
Is that them?
Is that supposed to be me?
The guys that movement don't just make great watches.
They also make awesome sunglasses and just realized a ton of new styles.
I'll just re released a ton of new styles.
What is wrong with me today?
Um,
all right,
here's my problem with sunglasses.
Evidently I got all these cheap pairs to look terrible.
No,
I don't.
I have nice sunglasses.
I have a couple cheapos and I fucking hate those,
but every time I buy a $200 pair,
I feel like I get ripped off.
That's not the truth.
Every time I spent $200 I ended up fucking losing it or sitting on him or drop
him on the pavement.
Well,
our friends at movement.
Yeah,
the watch guys,
they kind of felt the same way,
so they thought,
screw it.
Oh,
they're getting,
they're getting dangerous here.
How about we make quality trendy glasses at a fair price?
These things aren't plastic.
They're acetate acetate.
You can get them polarized.
Isn't there enough of that on Facebook and they just start at $70 they are
seriously going to be your goto shades.
These are high quality premium Acetate,
Acetate,
acetate frames,
no cheap plastic here.
You got to see these.
They have lots of styles to choose from.
Classy,
trendy,
round aviator mirrored polarized for him or for her.
You're sure to find the perfect pair.
Get 15% off today with free shipping and free returns by going to [inaudible]
dot com slash burr you know,
Movement for how they've revolutionized the watch industry.
Now's the time to check out this sunglasses.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr join the movement.
Oh Shit.
The black Tux,
everybody like the Ohio State University.
This is the black Tux.
These are the Tuxedos that those people on Ohio state were wearing when they
sold their jerseys and he got put on suspension.
Wedding season is upon us.
It's right,
it is.
You're going to be doing it big and going out to all of your buddies weddings.
I gotta be honest with you.
Weddings are actually great now.
Wedding sucked when I was a kid cause they was still like,
people weren't making them individual,
they just were all the same.
They will long and fucking boring and you would like,
when can we get to the bar?
Uh,
when you're bringing a date,
you want to look fresh,
but it has to be convenient.
That's where the black tux comes in to.
You're not even in the wedding and you're going to wear a Tuxedo to wedding.
That's fucking hilarious.
Going out dress the groom.
I liked the way these people are thinking.
The Blackstocks has awesome suits and Tuxedos and all kinds of styles and you
rent them online.
Oh,
I get it.
You gonna wear a suit.
The,
the black Tux offers the kinds of suits and Tuxedos styles that would normally
be wildly expensive to buy.
You might only wear it once,
like the Emerald Shawl Tuxedo.
It's funky.
It's cool.
But how many times are you going to wear an Emerald Green Tuxedo with the Black
Tux?
You can,
you can do you and blow it out for your one big event.
You're going to wear an Amarillo Green Tuxedo to somebody else's wedding.
You know,
when you do that,
you do that when you,
you used to be fucking the bride,
you know,
and she's doing that Douche move of inviting an old boyfriend to the wedding.
Brigid's friends.
We're at a good place.
By the way,
as a man,
you cannot allow that to happen.
You can not allow that to happen.
I mean,
I,
I would actually question whether I would even marry the person if they're
inviting an old boyfriend.
Uh,
with the Black Tux free home.
Try on.
You can see the fit and feel the quality of the suit months before your event.
Well,
you better make sure you eat well if he can to try it on that early after
ordering your suit will arrive 14 days before your event.
If anything is less than perfect.
If you put on a few pounds,
it took a few off.
I guess the Black Tux will send you a replacement right away.
Oh,
that's cool.
I remember bowel simple returns are where it turned heads than send it back
three days after your event.
Shipping is Triev both ways.
Stand out at your event for the right reasons with the Black Tux to get $20 off
your purchase,
visit the black tux.com/per.
That's the black tux.com/per for $20 off your purchase.
The black Tux premium rental suits and Tuxedos delivered.
All right,
one more.
Here we go.
stamps.com the US Postal Service is an important tool for any business.
stamps.com brings all the amazing services of the US Postal Service,
right to your fingertips to eating fingertips by and print official US postage
for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail using your own computer and printer stamps.com makes it easy.
They'll send you a digital scale that automatically calculates the exact postage
stamps.com we'll even help you decide the best class of mail based on your
needs.
No need to lease an expensive postage meter and there are no long term
commitments.
I use stamps.com uh,
because uh,
you know whenever I send out my post its which by the way you got to see the
poster for my tour coming up,
which is simply called 50.
All right.
The big five o people.
Um,
and I am actually sending posters over to Dublin and over to London.
That's the first place the posters with the tour officially gets kicked off.
Um,
and I actually am not going to be using stamps.com for that just because the
company's going to be sending it out themselves.
However,
when they send me the rest of the posters and I,
when I do Minnesota and all that,
I will be using stamps.com and right then I'm a moron if I could figure it out.
So can you,
and right now you too can enjoy stamps.
The stamps.com service with a special offer that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale.
Go to stamps.com.
Click on the microphone,
stop@thehomepageandtypeinburgerthatstamps.com enter burr.
And by the way,
uh,
in Dublin and in London,
I will be coming out after the show to take pictures and sign your posts or
something.
I that I have not done in fucking years.
Um,
I'm going to do that again because a,
I appreciate you guys coming out.
It is a big birthday.
Why not?
You know,
man,
God knows I'm not in the back drinking.
Ooh.
Although I think once I get through Dublin and once I get through London,
I think,
you know,
that's would be June 6th.
I think that's the night.
I might actually have a little,
uh,
a little stumped and who knows?
I don't know.
But you know,
I'm bringing my whole family over there.
I can't be hung over.
That's another reason why my daughter's the best.
Right.
She keeps me sober.
All right,
hang on one second.
I have to look something up here because now we're going to get into the
questions this week.
And um,
there's a point that somebody is bringing
some point that somebody bringing up about guns and they're doing it in the
usual way that people do it on the Internet where they insult the other person.
And I just want to make sure I have the definition of something up here.
Okay.
Bullshit.
Ar 15 response to goat guy
for those of you who don't listen all the time.
Um,
okay.
You know,
I,
you know,
there's a whole gun debate.
Why do you need an Ar 15?
So I was asking people that have a,
our 15th.
I said the why do you have one and don't give me that bullshit about fucking,
you know,
home defense and all of that crap.
I mean,
Jesus Christ.
you could,
I mean,
you could literally have a 22.
Oh you fuck.
Anybody want to get shot by a fucking 22?
I would have a 22 I did a whole bit on that just because I don't want to fucking
blow my ear drums out.
Okay.
I mean,
a fucking BB gun.
Okay.
You know,
we've got all those little fucking CO2 cartridges.
You shoot somebody in the fucking face with that.
They know what they gonna do.
They're going to keep that going to come,
keep walking through that,
then go down the street and just not have to worry about anything when they walk
into that house.
I don't know.
Anyways,
but you know,
or to fight off the government.
That's my,
another famous want.
No,
that's my other favorite one.
You're going to fight off the government with your fucking semiautomatic gun
here.
The whole government.
You're going to fight them all off.
Um,
I got a lot of bullets,
mother fucker.
All right.
So anyways,
so this guy ends up writing in saying that he was a sheep farmer or whatever,
goat farm or something like that.
Gold farmer and a,
he uses the milk to make a Parmigiano reggiano and he yells,
so you are so whenever the fuck he used two different types of cheese,
I forget what the other kid,
but both delicious types of cheese and there's all these coyotes and they hunt
in packs and he's shooting at a moving target and it just made fucking sense.
So then somebody else wrote back,
God,
that's bullshit.
Just get some fucking dogs.
They'll fight off the coyotes,
coyotes,
a coward,
this guy's full of shit.
And to be randomly killing coyotes like that,
you know,
mean and all that.
So this guy is responding to the person that responded to the guy because I was
impressed with that guy when he said that,
this is why I use it.
I'll go on.
Oh Shit.
That makes sense.
And I like that cheese.
So God bless you.
Kill those coyotes.
Right.
Um,
so my name's this guys responding to the person that said the tech guys still
didn't need the gunny could just get a couple of dogs.
So anyways,
he said,
hey pill,
I'd like to say to the guys response about just by dogs instead of an air of 15
does not know what the fuck he's talking about.
First of all,
it's not a machine gun.
You dumb cunt.
It's semi automatic rifle.
Meaning you pull the trigger once in one bullet fires.
Okay,
now do you see how he just made his point?
It's not a machine gun.
You dumb cunt.
It's a semiautomatic rifle.
You should say it's not a machine gun.
It's semiautomatic.
And then you should explain what semiotic Madec meets.
All right,
send me automatic doesn't just mean that you just pulled the trigger in one
bullet fires because then literally a fucking 38 is semiautomatic.
Doesn't that mean like you can,
you can actually pull the trigger quickly faster.
Yeah.
Where it won't get jammed or something like that mean there's something
different between just a fucking revolver,
a semiautomatic and fully automatic.
I don't know shit about guns.
Right.
But isn't there.
So I looked up semiautomatic firearm.
It says this,
without calling anybody a dumb cunt,
he just not informed.
There's a lot of information in the world.
You can't have it all between your ears,
semiautomatic,
firearm,
or a cell.
Floating firearm is one that not only fires a bullet each time the trigger is
pulled,
but also performs all steps necessary to prepare it to discharge.
Again,
assuming cartridges remain in the firearm feed device,
typically this includes extracting and ejecting the spent cartridge case from
the firing chamber.
Recopying the firing mechanism and loading a new cartridge into the fire firing
chamber to fire again,
the trigger is released.
Okay
to fire again.
The trigger is
okay.
Released and repressed again.
All right,
so now let me ask you this.
So is,
is it 38
okay,
because the revolver turns,
is that considered semiautomatic?
Now I'm just confused.
The semiautomatic,
let me look up.
Let me look this up.
Okay.
Is a revolver.
Yeah.
You know,
it's funny.
People were in the gun.
Right now,
the amount of people that are listening to me like I'm a fucking moron.
Like this means that they're better at math.
It's like I don't own guns.
I don't know anything about this shit.
If you didn't know anything about drums I wouldn't make funny cause you didn't
know what to fucking high hat was.
Is it a revolver?
Semiautomatic?
Let's see here.
Any hit search and it takes two hours.
A revolver,
which uses multiple chambers,
any single barrel in a derringer which uses multiple chambers in multiple bears.
Also fire one round per trigger pull,
but achieved this in different ways and as such are not classified as being
semiautomatic,
semiautomatic pistols.
Okay.
It's semi automatic pistol.
Is a type of pistol that is semiautomatic.
I swear to God.
That's the first statement.
Meaning it uses the energy of the fired cartridge to cycle the action of the
firearm and advanced to the next available cartridge into position.
So basically if I don't have some revolutionary war thing,
it's just like I buy,
put a bullet in,
shoot and then put another bullet in or I don't have to do that cocking thing
that you always see with the sniper rifles.
Yeah.
All right,
so this is sort of a basic gun there.
Okay.
This just like a car with power windows and power brakes,
power steering,
like most cars have that now.
Is that basically what you're saying when you were calling guy a dumb cunt?
He's not a dumb cunt.
I bet that Deca what did this guy,
what if he's a veterinarian?
It doesn't mean you're a dumb cunt.
All right.
Do you should've said you uninformed comment.
How about that?
Can we,
can we meet in the middle there and get,
still call him a cunt,
but just use the correct adjective?
MMM.
Anyways,
just like most rifles and handguns these days.
Oh,
you actually explained it to me if I considered continued reading.
Okay.
Uh,
first of all,
it's not a machine gun.
You'd dump con it's a semiautomatic rifle.
Me,
you pulled the trigger once and one bullet fires.
Just like most rifle and handguns these days,
right off the bat,
you know,
this guy doesn't know what he's talking about and probably never shot a gun in
his life.
Fair enough,
your honor.
That's all good.
I usually wouldn't be this hostile,
but hey,
I had a few drinks and I'm passionate about this subject.
All right,
fair enough.
Uh,
anyway,
I believe his argument was to buy a fleet of dogs to protect your livestock.
He didn't say a fleet.
He said,
you know,
I get like two or three.
He said,
get the fuck Outta here.
You know,
expensive train dogs are to protect your livestock.
I'm well do you?
Are you just drunk at a bar throwing this out?
I mean,
Christ purebred German shepherds are eight to $900 around here.
Now you're a moron.
No one's getting a German shepherd dipper.
You get like a fucking sheepdog or a Christ.
One of my buddies has one of those dogs.
There's smartest shit.
I forget the name of the dog.
He wouldn't.
You've seen and now you don't know about dogs.
He had dumb cunt.
You uninformed cont God knows what a fucking fleet of dogs cost.
Not to mention the food and attention.
You have to give him a or 15 prices are going down every day and with Ammo,
well under 50 cents around,
you'd have to be a dumb ass,
oh,
Jesus.
Parentheses or a liberal not to use this.
All right.
And right there,
your whole argument is out the window.
Yeah.
Anybody who classifies all conservatives or Republicans are all Liberals or
Democrats is morons right there.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
That's Kinda like what I was doing earlier when I was talking about how bad the
officiating was.
Okay.
Against the Bruins.
However,
I did bring up that,
you know,
Marshawn should have got a fucking misconduct for taking that guy's knees up.
Um,
and I did say that straight across the board.
It was,
it's been really fucking unprofessional.
Uh,
however,
but if I were to just sit there and say all the bad calls went against us,
I mean,
I don't know.
I would beat that would be,
oh,
well,
what kind of fucking world and kind of dual badge or liberal.
And I just made them out to all be southerners.
Like everybody down south is a dumb ass,
which is not trope
Mark Twain.
You know what I mean?
That guy was so smart.
He wrote all those books and Kentucky Fried Chicken had that guy dressed.
Just like in conclusion,
he said,
in conclusion,
as if he sees he's made this great argument,
uh,
I think there is a huge lack of education on farms in the u s today.
He actually wrote in the US today,
he didn't capitalize the u s um,
I would 100% agree with that.
At the end of the day,
the Ar 15 is the most effective tool for a lot of jobs.
A Psa.
Saleo Nashville,
your final bit fucking killed.
Love you and go fuck yourself sincerely.
Your freedom loving fans in Nashville.
Uh,
dude,
you know something?
I gotta be honest with you.
I agreed with your points,
but when you said dumb ass or liberal and the fact that you said freedom,
loving,
like who doesn't love to be free?
You know what I mean?
Are you another one of these peace people,
people that thinks that isis is a major threat to a first world country with
their no plane,
no boat,
no uniform,
no real weaponry,
modern weaponry,
fucking army.
You know what I mean?
Do you think if isis was,
uh,
living in the bad lands,
we would even waste of fucking second of our goddamn tax dollars to try and stop
him?
There's plenty of fucking consult there.
They're just not sitting on top of a bunch of fucking oil freedom.
Loving fucking,
you know,
something you've really,
you've really lost me there.
I mean,
if you don't agree with me,
I guess she just don't like freedom.
Yeah.
Boy,
what I at the amount of people that are drinking that fucking Koolaid 15 years
into this fucking thing,
okay,
it's a liberation.
They have weapons of mass destruction.
They've changed it like 90 fucking times.
And I'm so sick of the fact that you can't criticize what the fuck were those
fucking broke ass console over there are going to bankrupt us.
How long can you spend $700 billion a fucking year.
At some point we're going to have to pay for that.
I'm going to have to pay for it.
You're going to pay for it.
Our kids,
their kids and all of that.
Jesus fucking Christ over a bunch of jerk offs with a bag of mad
unfucking,
believable.
Unbelievable.
You know why we're over there.
Sit Down,
knew why we went over there.
He lit it on fire before we got there,
but you can't say that anymore in this country because if you'd do that means
you're an isis or you're a socialist or some shit like that.
It's just fucking,
it's unbelievable.
It's unfucking believable be,
wow,
this place is going to hell in a hand basket with a nationwide heroin epidemic.
Our food supply is fucking poison and the got the houses back so they can cook
the economy again.
All of that is fine.
All of that is fine,
but you should tell jokes at a fucking
presidential.
Whatever the fuck that is,
the whole God damned world stops.
All right.
This girl,
uh,
Billy blowfish,
love you.
Delete blowfish.
I like that.
Love your podcast.
I've been listening to it every time I'm in the car.
Driving to and from work definitely makes my commute better.
Listen,
I'm a 22 year old guy and I've been talking to this girl who has a kid.
Now I know what you're thinking.
What the fuck is going through your stupid fucking head.
Uh,
but the problem is is I think I really liked this girl.
I don't think that's a problem.
As long as you're willing to take on the responsibilities of that relationship
is nothing wrong with it.
And I,
one thing I forgot to mention,
I haven't even met her in person yet.
Uh,
okay.
I just,
I just dropped the microphone on that one.
I'm supposed to meet her.
I supposed to meet up with there.
Okay.
I just saw you were stalking her on social media.
I'm supposed to meet her.
I was supposed to go meet her up this Saturday.
Is that a new expression?
I think you said you didn't think you meant to say meet up with her this
Saturday night after work and I'm not sure what will happen.
The thing is she's exactly like me.
She's vegetarian,
she likes animals and nature,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
What's the Nashville Guy doing right now?
Yeah,
she likes all that but doesn't laugh.
Um,
but she has a fucking kid bill.
I'm fucking 22 years old and can't stop thinking about this girl who has a
fucking kid.
Please give me some advice.
I'm not sure how to proceed.
Well I think you're very concerned with the responsibilities of the fact that
she has a kid and what that's gonna mean and you're only 22 years old and
there's fucking nothing wrong with that.
Okay.
And don't let all these fucking don't don't ask a woman about this cause she's
just going to stick up for the fucking woman because she's going to insert
herself into that situation would be like,
well,
I'd still like to be able to find love just cause I have a kid to,
you're 22 years old,
you are a kid.
All right.
Unless you're like really mature or something like that,
that that is a major,
uh,
detail that you should be thinking about.
All right?
So,
uh,
I would respect the fact that there's a voice in your head that's saying,
dude,
she's got a fucking kid.
All right.
Before,
uh,
you know,
because I would tell you right now,
dude,
like what's you're getting involved in there?
You know,
if that goes south,
you're going to break two hearts.
Okay.
Cause there's two people that are going to fall in love with you in that thing.
So make sure you're,
you're prepared and you don't waste her time and that poor kid's time.
All right,
so there you go.
That's my advice to you.
This isn't,
you know,
oh look at it.
Tits.
I want to fuck her or this is not that situation,
you know.
All right.
Advice Dick,
that douchebag friend,
dear Billy angel tits.
Um,
I didn't know what that means.
Anytime anybody calls me an angel,
I take that as a compliment.
Um,
I guess cause there is white as an angels gown,
maybe it's an insult.
I don't know.
Billy red tits,
Billy devil tits.
It can go either way on that.
Um,
love the podcast.
I thank you a sense you're always offering great wisdom and words to live by.
I'm really not.
I'm a fucking moron and you guys listen to me for some reason.
Maybe you could help me out with this one for the sake of a nymity hope I said
that right.
Let's call this Douche bag friend of mine.
Dick Dick is the kind of person that can get annoying and touchy towards women
when he's drunk to the point where it starts to border on harassment.
It's always weird.
It always weirds me the fuck out and I don't know how to address this behavior.
Simple be like,
hey deck where you fucking knock it off.
Well.
What's wrong with you?
Keep your hands.
See Yourself.
He goes,
a few weeks ago,
he met this 18 year old girl at a bar.
What the fuck she doing at a bar,
which we had a great time with.
We all went to Dick's house afterwards for a couple more dicks drink,
sorry.
And Dick tried to make some moves on this girl.
He couldn't get into her pants that night.
However,
however,
last Friday he did.
Now this is where it gets crazy.
The next day he took the girl to a yearly festival to celebrate Liberation Day
where he and I and a whole bunch of friends I had planned to meet up.
This is obviously from another country,
I don't know,
a liberation day.
She basically only knew me and him about 15 minutes into meeting each other
there,
the girls started puking up foam.
As it turns out,
she hadn't eaten all day and it popped a pill of ecstasy,
which he had given to her.
Oh my God.
He didn't seem to care what was happening.
So I decided to take her to the bathroom area to clean her up and I brought her
some water and then we went back to look for Dick.
Well,
why would you take her back to him?
When we finally found him,
let me guess.
He was trying to hook up with somebody else.
I told Dick like to,
she hasn't eaten all day,
man.
She was puking back there and you should get her son to eat.
And what did this mother fucking do?
He quickly walked away and left me to deal with this 18 year old chick for the
rest of the entire day.
We didn't see him again for the rest of the day and we made no effort in trying
to,
he made no effort and trying to find us what a Dick being the gentleman that I
am,
I decided to stay with to guide her through this ecstasy trip.
Uh,
I gave her some food and tried to have fun and even though we did have fun,
it had already ruined that day for me.
He tried to contact me today,
but I'm really questioning whether he even deserves a response.
What do you think,
Bill?
Should I give this ticket another chance or it's just the kind of person you
want to cut out of your life.
Complete me things.
I'll tell you too.
This is the no brainer.
I pick up the phone and I would just tell him like,
dude,
you are a fucking piece of shit and your behavior around women is completely
unacceptable.
To the point I would warn other women to stay away from you and I don't want to
be friends with a person like you have a nice life and God bless the United
States of America.
I mean that's it.
That's an easy one.
I don't even have to think about that one.
All right.
Fuck banks.
Bill,
I'm writing to you because I believe you are the only man crazy and angry enough
to relate with me on this dude.
Fuck banks.
Fuck them all this month I just found out I owe my bank $45 apparently fitness
connection attempted to withdraw $10 from my account these past two months.
Once a month at about $5 in my bank two months ago.
This could not cover the $10 fee a month for my gym membership twice.
So now I'm being charged a fee of 40 dive $5 even though one it's debit to
fitness,
didn't actually withdraw the money.
They only attempted to,
nothing went through.
So not only do I owe my bank $45 Buddy,
oh so fitness connection about 50 in late fees and the $2 to $10 fees that never
got paid.
Please explain to me why I'm being charged for this transaction that didn't go
through.
Is there a guy working in the dark room at the bank pushing buttons who they
have to pay for the transaction services?
No,
it's all fucking ones and Zeros.
All computers.
Yet another fee that we as consumers,
except for no reason at all,
even if it makes no sense.
The idea of letting an entities such as a bank holds your money,
seems to carry way more cons than it does parks.
I'm taking your advice and I'm going to call and complain until I get what I
want.
Fuck banks forever.
Now.
All my money lives in the walls.
If the house burns down then so be it.
But at least I didn't get fucked by the man.
Keep the good work and good luck to you Celtics.
Jason Tatum is looking like a baller.
All right.
I agree with a lot of things you're saying there,
but what you didn't take responsibility for was your own actions that led to
this.
All right?
If you know that you owe your gym $10 a month,
you're going to have to fucking have that in your bank account.
You didn't have that.
So then,
um,
I don't know how it works.
I know you write a check the,
and it bounces.
There's a fee.
So you're saying this is debit,
but you're using your debit like paying cash and everything.
So I actually don't think banks are out of line for doing that.
Why would I think is you need to be more responsible with the money and like I
agree with you.
Banks are fucking evil.
It's a giant Ponzi scheme.
Um,
there's nothing behind the fucking money,
but everybody believes in it.
So,
hey,
we live another day.
All right.
Um,
but the thing about it is,
is you have to learn to make money work for you.
And if you don't understand money,
the wonderful thing about the internet is if you stop,
you know,
reading people screaming about politics or watching online porn and all of that
Shit,
which I've been guilty of,
all of that stuff,
that's actually a lot of things that you can learn.
And,
um,
what I've learned about money is that money can set you free or it can in
prison.
You,
and it all depends on the choices that you're making and the choices that you're
making.
Sur are horrific and back in the day would have landed you and all of your
family and to debtor's prison.
So you got off easy in the modern world.
Um,
uh,
you know,
I guess taking your money out of the banks,
putting you in your walls.
I,
you know,
I don't disagree with that past a certain amount of fucking money,
but,
uh,
I,
I like to invest in things that are tangible.
I'm into real estate.
I'm into buying apartment buildings.
And Shit like that.
Um,
you always have to hedge your bets.
Like I'm buying apartment buildings,
just starting to do that.
And I was like,
I bought a bunch of looking at one,
right?
Because it fascinates me to have income coming into my house every month.
That's not actually in the business that I'm in and the business that I'm in now
considering now with social media,
somebody can just say,
you did something and there's no,
um,
what do you call it?
There's no due process or anything.
And that could literally cause everybody in the business you're in to just walk
away from you and then,
then what do you do?
You know?
So,
uh,
and that's just a new pitfall in this fucked up business that I'm in,
which,
you know,
even before all that,
me too.
Shit,
I mean you,
you see these movie stars,
one hit after another,
one after another,
and all of a sudden they have a couple of flops in a row and then they just
disappear.
So this business has always been fickle as hell.
So I planned on doing this anyways.
But after all of that stuff came out and like,
you know,
just recently looking at Tom Brokaw stuff,
I don't know if he's guilty or innocent,
but the fact that two people can just accuse him
and which is their right,
but the amount of people that just on the accusations now just look at that guy
like he's a complete piece of shit is uh,
isn't right,
is it isn't any more right than if he actually did what they said they were
doing.
And then he's actually guilty of it.
But to just,
you know,
an accusation,
it's just an accusation.
But the amount of people that then take that as,
you know,
the game set match is,
um,
I mean it's just how the world works.
It's just how it works.
So,
um,
you need to learn about money.
Can't just say fuck banks and then just be antisocial and have your like money
in the walls.
I mean,
you can use banks as long as you know what,
what,
what the game is,
you can use it in your favor.
And,
um,
and if you just resist
the stupidity of consumption and flat screen TVs and all of this shit that these
stupid fucking celebrity show you when they go into their houses and all,
I had this stupid,
they all,
what they're showing you is a,
a fucking,
the only thing that's impressive is that house,
everything else is,
uh,
is it?
There's a liability.
It's all depreciating assets.
They're fucking cars,
all of that shit.
You know what I mean?
Those stupid supercar that does fucking idiots buy that.
You know,
the only place you really should be taken it is to a track she can actually
know,
open the thing up.
And then all of those cards,
like,
you know,
you look at those four gts,
I saw one the other day for sale and it was like fucking 10,
15 years old and it was high miles.
It had 6,000 miles on it.
Now it retained most of its value,
but it's just,
I dunno,
I guess unless you're going to buy those things,
but all of those flat screen TVs,
the monogram fucking stupid shit,
the oil painting yourself,
it's just a bunch.
It's a bunch of shit.
It's fucking stupid.
Um,
the pots and pans that you buy that rather than just buying the ones that
target,
you go out and you gotta go to fucking foofy Foose fucking place and getting by
the,
these Gore may level fucking pots and pans to heat up.
We have fish sticks because at the end of the day,
you're still dead blue collared jerk off.
It's all a fucking waste of money and it's just a bunch of shit.
Now,
if you actually take your money right,
you know,
and,
and learn how to invest it,
and then your money starts making money.
That's when you flip it.
When your money is earning you fucking money.
When you're fucking sitting on a couch watching a game and your money is out
there and making you fucking money,
then you understand it.
Um,
and I mean,
I don't even understand it.
Okay.
But I'm just starting to learn how to do it.
And the,
the,
I don't,
they just,
it's nowhere in the educational system.
You have to seek out that knowledge yourself.
Like most
quality knowledge that's out there,
you have to seek it out because people aren't going to give it to you.
So that's what I would say.
So I feel few that you're in that position.
I've been in that position,
but uh,
I wouldn't say fuck banks use banks rather than have bank.
Shoo.
All right.
There you go.
It's a long explanation,
but an important subject.
All right.
My sister's dead beat boyfriend.
Dear terror,
Billy.
I mean,
what that means.
I'm a,
I'm a junior in high school and I live with my mother,
sister and her dead beat boyfriend.
Wow.
Uh,
he moved in with intentions to pay rent and help fix up our house.
That is slowly falling apart.
Is this Dwight Yoakam from fucking a sling blade,
but for the past year,
this losers had no job and pass paid no rent.
Yeah.
He's a gold digging whores.
Uh,
all he does is sleep all day and play Xbox.
He also mentally manipulates my sister by telling her things like her family
doesn't care enough about her to give her a funeral.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
You got to get this guy out of the house while he gets high and drunk and totes
is guns around.
My mom has on multiple occasions threatened to kick him out because,
but she won't in fear that my sister will go with him.
What in the fuck is
I,
I don't even understand how a parent loses his level of control in their own
house.
So bill,
what do you think I should do about this situation?
Thank you for being sit damn fire.
Thank you.
All right,
looking forward to season three a,
what do you think I should do?
Um,
yeah,
you got to sit down and talk to your mom
and he just say,
mom,
I know this is a difficult situation,
but you got to kick this guy out of the house.
Um,
he's drunk and he's,
he's,
he's walking around with guns.
You got to choose your family first.
And if our sister chooses him over us,
then so be it.
I mean,
that's it,
dude.
You got to get that guy out of the fucking house.
Fuck that loser.
That's it.
These are all cut and dry as this week dumped at fucking Douche.
Banded that check after he gave her the ecstasy learn,
you know,
learn how to fucking use money correctly and get this fucking guy out of the
house.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
I feel like I'm cheating on a test here.
These are easy this week.
Sit Down with your mom and just say,
we've got to kick this guy out.
Um,
okay.
And this is what I would do.
I would,
um,
if you need to,
I would call the cops before you kick them out.
If you think he's going to be a problem.
I would have the cops come down there and say,
ah,
I don't want this guy in my house anymore.
He does have firearms and I want them out of the house.
Um,
what a fucking loser.
Alright.
Dumped because of infidelity 20 years ago.
A big Billy Ball balls,
massive fan of the podcast and your specials have had me in stitches.
Oh,
thank you.
Um,
I really need your advice,
opinions,
sliced advice on a situation with recent issues.
I've just broken up with an amazing lady.
The woman I was going to propose to this month.
We had been to get together eight months.
When you get to your late 30 she can cut through the bullshit pretty quickly and
get to a meaningful relationship.
I knew she was the one I want him to spend the rest of my life with.
Our relationship had been great.
No arguments,
lots of fun,
laughter and love.
Only one issue existed between us and it seems to have caused the end of the
relationship not long after we started dating.
We were out having drinks and we were talking lately about past relationship and
she asked if I'd ever been unfaithful.
I want it to be honest and said yes.
She asked to know more and I just described a time when I was 20 and I had been
an idiot and cheated on my girlfriend at the time.
I stressed that I regretted it and have never entertained the thought of doing
that again.
I am simply not the same guy.
She reacted barely badly leaving the pub crying outside before coming back in
and telling me she wished I'd lied.
We managed to get past it though.
That night,
Dude,
you were 20 the relationship went on his normal.
We shared many weekends and holidays,
Fun Nights out,
cozy nights in,
talked about a future together and I was invited to share Christmas and new
years with their entire family was great.
Even as recently as last week,
she was redesigning my garden for use in the summer.
It is rear its head two more times since then.
One saw my birthday in January when we nearly broke up over it and she was
struggling with it again.
She was so upset,
kept saying,
why couldn't you have just lied?
But we talked through and moved on again or so I thought and then of course
recently when it all ended,
every time it has come up had been honest and shown true remorse and been very
supportive.
Very recently we broke up because she just can't get past my past and said it's
the only thing stopping her from committing to me fully.
She loves me.
Wanted to be talking about having shoulder with me,
blah,
blah.
I don't need to reread the less this.
Everywhere you look,
all you hear is the once a cheater,
always a cheater lines.
What should my case simply is not true.
I know
that's some of this stems from one of her past relationship,
which ended 2016 when she was engaged and the guy broke it off and ran off in
front of her friends.
I don't want to lose this lady.
Only back on Valentine's Day,
she made me present.
Okay.
Back on Valentine's Day.
She made me a present of a lot of reasons why she loves me.
One of them was that she thinks about the future.
She only saw it with me and then I made her feel like no one else has.
This can surely be saved,
but I don't understand it and I don't know what to do.
Thanks bill and go fuck yourself.
Well,
I mean,
what the fuck can you do?
if she's going to judge you by what you did when you were 20 years old,
I just laid on table said,
listen,
I want to marry you.
All right,
well there's nothing I could do to make,
you know,
I'm paying for the sins of that last guy.
And if you want to throw this relationship because of that away,
because of that last guy that's on you.
Dude,
you've done all you can do here,
need done,
all you can do here.
So she's obviously not over that other guy or the pain of that other guy and now
you're paying for it.
Um,
yeah,
I dunno.
So I mean what the fuck can you do?
I would just tell her how I feel about her and just say,
listen,
I'm ready to get married anytime you want to,
but um,
if you don't,
then you got to let me go and I got to move on.
I got to get,
you know,
cause I'm in my late thirties and if you don't trust me enough that I'm not
going to fuck around on you,
then I,
you know,
I don't want to tell you
did,
I guess it is over,
but it's going to be your call.
It's not my call.
Something like that.
I Dunno.
That's a tough one buddy.
All right.
The last one,
last one at Jesus's along pockets.
Did I blow my chances with this girl from work?
Hello,
Bill Nye the angry guy.
I'll keep this as short as I can.
Who just opened that door?
Hey Buddy.
Hey,
what's up cutie pie?
Um,
I guess I'm watching you right now.
Hi.
What's going on?
Don't pull the cord.
All right.
Yeah.
Help me out with this one guys acid that I blow my chances with this girl from
work.
Hello,
Bill Nye the angry guy.
I'll keep it short as I can.
I work with this girl that is a solid 10.
She's absolutely gorgeous and a personality matches mine in a hundred different
ways and she's a nerdy chick,
which is a massive plus.
If you saw her,
you'd say,
holy s,
why does she work in a place like this?
Can Curse my kids here a quick and simple.
I got to know her.
We constantly flirted back,
back and forward,
not back and forth near.
They flirted back and forward.
Uh,
she put a lot of attention on me.
Not to sound egotistical,
but I'm a good looking.
I thought he said 62 year old guy's six foot two guy.
My issue is that when I get too comfortable,
I began to spill my red flags and I start to describe my self confidence issues.
I guess I do this to see if she's okay with them.
Bad move.
Yes it is.
After working with her for nearly a year and a half now she seems distant.
Yeah,
you probably weighed two.
What?
We used to watch the same shows,
not physically together,
but then come to work the next day and have long conversations about hos and
though they were,
she used to make efforts to initiate conversation.
Now she barely acknowledges me anymore.
It was,
it was really sudden.
Well,
she probably met someone.
I'm not trying to be a dick here.
I've tried,
uh,
a lot to strike up conversation,
but she acts this interested.
I started trying to make her jealous,
but she doesn't seem to give a f.
Uh,
we work in a almost exclusive male workplace,
so of course everyone is trying to get with her.
It burns my blood to watch it,
but it's my fault.
Is there anything I can do to resist the perverse,
my situation or vice sealed this case shut.
Thanks for reading.
Please come to,
I'm not going to say the city in case she's listening.
Um,
yeah,
I think you blew it with her.
The only girlfriend broke up with you.
Your work girlfriend broke up with.
Yeah.
I think what you need to do is move on and uh,
stop talking about your confidence issues.
He need to get some confidence in.
You need to get outside the workplace and you need to start hitting on some
women and he need to go on dates and then you're going to feel more confident
about yourself.
And that's the best way to try and make this woman more interested in you.
All right.
Don't s where you eat anyway,
right.
Don't ask where you eat.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
Well,
this guy doesn't have confidence,
so he's not going to walk up to a woman that doesn't really know he needs to get
over that hub,
which is why it works.
Because there's a reason they're supposed to be there.
He feels more comfortable and he,
you know,
she was probably waiting for him to ask around and then he didn't.
And then now it sounds like she's with somebody else.
Yeah.
Or She's just over his,
just over it,
you know,
that'll fun.
Like I said,
work boyfriend,
girlfriend relationship and now she's moved on.
There you go.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
yeah.
Do plenty of fish in the sea,
you know,
and don't waste your time getting jealous,
but this person just like you go in there,
you know,
you don't care.
Huh?
Hi.
Okay.
Yeah.
What's up?
Smiley.
Hi.
Please say hi.
Um,
you know,
it's funny now as she speaks jibberish but she knows exactly what she's saying
and then she'll just throw in a random real world.
Should be like,
I should check,
check,
check.
Hi,
Huh?
Yeah.
You want to tell some stories?
All right.
That's the podcast for this week a go.
You know what yourselves and I'll check in on you on Thursday.
Bye.
Yeah.
Congratulations to the Tampa Bay lightning.
Yup.
Bunch of BS.
All right.
I'll talk to you later.